okay china's bike dance the makers of
tick tock has killed the 996 work
schedule and it's mandating that
employees only work between 10 am and 7
pm monday to friday
996 if you don't know
was what people in china in the tech
industry were working that means nine
a.m to nine pm six days a week which by
the way when i was coming up in new york
in the media world specifically were
considered the hours if you wanted to
work at conde nast or the new york times
or any magazine you're expected to get
in the morning stay till late at night
you would eat at your desk you would
order dinner in most nights of the week
or you go out to dinner you might come
back to the office afterwards and you
were expected to come in on a saturday
or sunday do four or five hours and get
ahead for the next week
the world has changed obviously and in
china specifically
xi jinping has got a different world
view and he's de-emphasizing you know
these celebrity ceos like jack ma
he's hasn't left the country in a long
time i think it's two years or so
and
he is charting a new path for china
which is certainly more insular and part
of that is really getting into the
social fabric of how people live their
lives we saw their video game
changes and how much people were allowed
to use video games and now we're seeing
work hours come in bloomberg reviewed an
internal document from bite dance
according to the article the document
would make byte dance quote one of the
first tech companies in china to
officially mandate shorter working hours
some of silicon valley thought the 996
schedule would push china ahead of the
us sequoyah's michael moritz the
greatest venture capitalist of all time
according to many and the statistics uh
so it's pretty close to true it's
definitely top four of all time mount
rushmore he wrote a financial times
article back in january 2018 which was
vilified by some on the uh woke far left
uh silicon valley would be wise to
follow china's lead because
if we're going to be competitive and
there are entrepreneurs there who are
working those kind of hours on very
important projects whether they're space
projects or their ai projects or
healthcare
related biotech projects we do need to
keep pace and now we're seeing something
different out of china
the bloomberg article noted under the
new policy employees can apply to work
overtime no more than three hours on a
weekday or eight hours on a weekend
according to the document they will
receive
extra compensation of up to three times
their normal wage
the overtime permission to work overtime
must be requested at least one day in
advance
the article also notes that earlier this
year by dance quote cancelled an
alternating system where employees just
take one day off per week every two
weeks which is crazy
13 days of work every 14. that sounds
like a recipe for disaster
on october 13th bloomberg reported the
workers lives matter movement currently
occurring in china that's an interesting
co-opting of
black lives matter the movement included
a spreadsheet where chinese tech and
finance employees
shared quote what time they start and
their work day as well as how many days
per week they work as of october 13th
the article had
4 000 entries so i should say the
spreadsheet had 4000 entries right now
the spreadsheet links to a
blank page so it's probably deleted it
appears that this grassroot effort is
working
across a lot of other big companies the
sheet called working time has been
viewed more than 10 million times
according to the south china morning
post reporting so very interesting
workers getting a say and uh maybe
yeah it's hard to know what's going on
in china
and hard to know
how this will play out but definitely
china is
charting a new course
and everybody who's an expert on china
did not see
the decapitation of their
top tech ceos or the limiting of video
games the limiting of working hours
as
what china's new strategy would be in
fact everybody thought the opposite they
thought china would out hustle us
work harder maybe be more
entrepreneurial take more companies
public so this certainly is something
very weird that's going on there
and so we'll keep an eye on it but for
me in america
i tell everybody in my companies uh if
you want to be a startup company a
finance company i think a fixed 50 a
solid 60 hours a week is what will get
you ahead in your career don't want
people working 78 hours a week
at this point in my career i'm
successful enough the companies are
successful enough that
people i mean there are some people who
i'm sure work 78 hours a week who just
love it and are obsessed with their work
and are super go-getters but it is a
recipe for burnout and for me at this
point in my career i'm trying to get
people to stick with me for five or ten
years
uh and grow and build their careers if
you want to keep people for five or ten
years especially when they're working
from home and all this burnout culture
you know if people want to punch a clock
they're probably not going to you know
if they do 40 hours a week i don't think
you're going to move forward in your
career
you're going to maybe fall behind if you
do a fix 50 or a solid 60 is the way i
phrase it uh you put that extra 10 20
hours a week in self-improving that
could be reading a book that could be
taking extra meetings
you know catching up on the weekends on
some email for an hour or two while you
drink your coffee you know those kind of
things are what got me ahead in in my
career and different strokes for
different folks if you don't want to
move faster in your career than other
people totally get that
i wouldn't work at a startup i work at a
big company because at a startup that
might
might uh make you an outcast if you're
not keeping pace now some people are
super wildly efficient i've seen people
work 40 hours a week and do more than
somebody doing 60 or 70 hours a week
where they're just hanging out at the
office but that's over now work from
home changes this whole game so you know
work from home people can just see when
you report on what you did this week or
you talk about in the staff meeting what
projects you're completing and
everything's written down
so you kind of see in people's weekly or
daily reporting what they're getting
done so i think the performative nature
of staying at the office all hours which
i do know some people did
i certainly did that in my early days i
would come in early and i wouldn't leave
until my boss left a lot of times i was
there and it's like six or seven o'clock
i know my boss is gonna leave at nine
and i'd say what do i do for the next
two hours what can i do when i go find a
book about novel networking or banyan
vines or document management i would
just teach myself a new skill but i
would never ever leave before my boss or
my boss's boss now my boss would leave
at exactly five
you know oh one they would literally be
at the elevator 459 5 501 to catch like
the train to long island at 5 25
but i always looked at my boss's boss
who was mike savino and i said i'll
leave when mike savino leaves i'm not
leaving until he leaves and he would
work till eight or nine o'clock and then
once in a while he'd say hey what are
you doing here kid i'm like i'm catching
up on this and i show him what i'm
working he goes hey you want to go get a
bite to eat we go around the corner
manhattan get a bite to eat and that's
how he started a lifelong friendship and
he mentored me
and my career made huge jumps because of
that work ethic so think it through if
you're an entrepreneur
from websites and online stores to
marketing tools and analytics
squarespace is the all-in-one platform
to build a beautiful online presence and
run your business with squarespace you
can blog or publish content promote your
business announce upcoming events or
special projects sell products and
services of all kinds and
more no matter what the problem
squarespace is the answer you know that
and they have these beautiful templates
by world-class designers powerful
ecommerce functionality and everything
you do is optimized for mobile right out
of the box you also got built-in seo
free and secure hosting and of course
their 24 7 award-winning customer
support that you're not going to get if
your cousin builds your website and puts
it on his backup server trust me back in
2020 we decided to create a new idea
during the pandemic we called it remote
demo day we have founders pitch to
thousands of angel investors over video
conferencing and we purchased the domain
name remote demo day.com and had the
site up and running in minutes thanks to
our friends at squarespace and remote
demo day has been a huge success so far
we've invested almost 20 million dollars
in those companies pretty great so go to
squarespace.com twist for a free trial
and when you're ready to launch use that
offer code twist to save ten percent off
your first purchase of a website or
domain and congrats to the team for
going public back in may what an amazing
journey great job squarespace team